Sa nay ngày 11 tháng 12 năm, không ăn sạv những lột phối hợp có đình bị nghiệp của công an thành phố Xí Minh tích tục phong tỏ hút vực hiện chương.
Lấy lời khai những người liên quan trông vụ án mạng khiến bà lời hát quý, sống biệt bà tuổi từ vòng.
Thông tin bà đầu, khoảng chính giường mối phút hồn qua, ông S, sống biệt tuổi, đi săng nhà hàng sống là bà quý trong hình đường vụ đổi an đến.
Tại đây, S đã tình công bà quý từ vong để cứ tài sản, sau khi về an S lời lắp tầy và đối bông kai của nạn nhân,
dùng tấm bà chè thì tì thể dùi kéo ra sau hệ nhằm chè dấu.
Đến chìu, người thân bà quý đi làm về khu khế bà nên tổ chức tình kiếm trong đó có cả S tham gia để đánh lạng lạng luy rồi.
Đến tôi cùng ai, tí thể bà quý được phát hiện trong tấm bà phía sau nhà nên ra đình trình bà công an.
Từ khám hiện hiện trường bà chiếc sức cà mi ra, công an sát định S là người phạm và tính hạnh bà sức.
Tại các quan đưa chà, S thai só tùng thiếu đến nay sình ý định cứ tài sản,
sau khi sát hạnh nạn nhân S chảy sẽ mấy đi bán tài sản cứu được tệ một tìm vang cách nhà không ra.
Từ lời hai bán đầu và quá trình ra sóa, công an trợ tập thêm một phụ lưới là vỡ S để làm só hình vì linh quan.
Hình vùng việc đăng đưa chà, làm só.